Zhong Yak Yong was a sillhawk scholar, politician,
poet and inventor of the late Joseon Dynasty
who presented innovative ideas in various fields,
and his ideas and techniques still have a great influence today.
His most innovative contribution
may be his critical ideas about political and social systems.
Zhang advocated for improving the quality of life of the people
and reforming the political system based on social fairness.
His work, Mockman Seamsell,
contained his deep insight into how rulers should govern their people,
which contained universal values that could be applied
not only to Joseon but also to modern society.
In addition, it contributed to the development of IQ
thiology in Joseon by systematically classifying and recording
Joseon's fishery resources through Jasun Aoba.